aux etats unis la cia opère quelques
changements après avoir annoncé avoir
perdu des dizaines d'informateurs dans
le monde les agences de renseignement
revoit ses priorités fini les missions
spéciales autour de l'iran et de la
corée du nord qui seront désormais
attribués à des unités plus large place
à une unité 100% dédié à la chine un
service mis en place dans un contexte de
tensions entre pékin et washington lé
précision avec notre correspondant
thomas bonnin
sur le dossier chinois washington semble
souffler le chaud et le froid après
avoir annoncé ce mercredi qu'un
entretien aurait lieu d'ici la fin de
l'année entre les deux présidents
américain et chinois on a appris ce
jeudi la création au sein de la cia
d'une nouvelle unité 100% dédié à la
chine qui est présenté dans le
communiqué comme la menace géopolitique
la plus importante du 21e siècle une
preuve que washington s'inscrit dans une
rivalité à long terme avec pékin tout au
long de son histoire la cia à relever
tous les défis auxquels elle a été
confrontée alors que nous faisons face
aujourd'hui à d'autres défis
géopolitiques le plus difficile dans une
nouvelle ère de rivalité entre grandes
puissances la cia va jouer un rôle
primordial la création de cette unité au
sein de la cia intervient dans un
contexte tendu entre les deux pays
puisque au delà des questions
commerciales il ya surtout la question
de taiwan qui agite les tensions en ce
moment il ya eu des révélations de la
part du goal street journal qui affirme
que des troupes américaine stationne à
taiwan depuis au moins un an des membres
des forces spéciales qui entraînerait
les troupes taïwanaise cela risque
d'accentuer à des tensions déjà très
vives dans la région puisque le ministre
taïwanais de la défense elle déclarait
il ya peu que les relations avec la
chine était au plus bas depuis 40 ans
washington qui a aussi dénoncé des
opérations militaires chinoises dans la
région de taïwan et puis le son côté
pékin considère l'île devront rappelle
comme une partie de son territoire et
appel rés q lièrement washington à
respecter les accords en vigueur et à ne
pas fournir de soutien militaire à l'île
de taïwan